je m'appelle gerbe
j'avais 21 ans quand on a tourné ce film
l'année dernière je m'interdis et
j'avais 28 ans qu'on a tourné ce film
tu revenais de rouen oui j'ai enseigné
là bas comme l'acteur
moi c'est passé ce voyage c'est bien
quand vous
j'ai beaucoup d'élèves
non pas vocalement
c'est de moins en moins maintenant
jusqu'au les accents bonne
j'organisais des programmes éducatifs
pour deux américaines en europe
jay est ce que vous allez faire
maintenant je retourne chez moi
et puis je ne sais pas vous faire le
dîner peut-être plus et moi nous nous
irons au cinéma je sais pas vous allez
faire comme l'idée
bon petit effort vous enseignez à qui
cette les étudiants français aux
facultés des lettres qui fait des études
d'anglais et a oscillé les études
américaines vouent leur enseigner quoi
rose la littérature est une histoire ma
visite en amérique quand vous rentrez
chez-vous ville est en train de jouer de
l'orgue
oui toujours et je frappe à la porte et
d'internet et puis c'est fini clôture
vous l'entendez quand vous montez les
escaliers tout de même à au troisième
étage
qu'est ce que vous faites maintenant
vous allez faire maintenant je travaille
est longue un peu où je tape un peu la
thèse ça dépend où est-ce que c'est
celle ici
c'est toujours l'un à non nous habitent
près tu aurais des romains n'ont pas
beaucoup changé
les beaux quartiers cette fête euros
voire appartement c'était au comptant ce
qu'on avait tout cela c'est bien sa vie
secrète vous demandez un peu de jeu pose
des questions on s'est peut-être non
c'est nous qui votre mère oui de manière
dit qu'elle met sur avait son
anniversaire alors qu'il est avec toi
elle dit que mon anniversaire
elle a 18 ans a maintenant été 18 ans
vraiment on peut être tué les garçons ne
devienne légale sans merci avec trente
ans que mathieu n'est pas 1 400 pour
cette présence et avec eux on ne peut
pas faire prendre de plus en plus
embêtant les choses qu est ce qu on fait
n'importe quand on dit ça fait rien
jean lé plus en plus mauvais avons acté
c'est mon héros
vous avez fait pour amener ça ici à les
gens qui a monté par l'escalier et on a
eu pour une discothèque associés
coûteront tout l'escalier du matin si
vous essayez c'est possible mais il a
dit qu'il faut partir sa part a cédé
moi j'ai peur d'être tournée
je ne veux pas mettre main commencer
maintenant acheter tous les meubles sa
forme beaucoup d'étranges ça coûte
beaucoup d'argent et dès qu'on commence
il faut admettre cordes inspiré et je ne
veux pas ça
c'est une pièce j'ai écrit pour un
examen
vous ne regrettez pas un peu ce quartier
beaucoup les les les commerçantes et
très gentil qui n'existent pas
d'interpréter maintenant
vaut mieux pourquoi nous américanisé
comme ça va rien les conditions ne sont
pas une manière de vivre à la française
ça vous paraît qui s'en dédit moi aimer
aimer les petits commerçants est-ce
qu'il y en a là dans les petits colliers
temps avec qui on fait la conversation
les ghettos bidonvilles
le gas oil à 14,2 et noir ou
territoriale et des choix sains et moir
300 membres en ce temps j'ai chaque
ruelle
j'étais marché le gâteau ricard et
amassant peut acheter des choses
rentrent pas dans la plupart
l'insurrection
avec quelque 3 des clients américains
général et américaine en invitant ses
hôtes
c'est un peu mon passé prétend mener